hi I'm poppy do you want to see
something interesting what go
hi I'm striker hi second why are you
here
I'm pretty sure you materialized me with
your special glitter but I can't
remember oh are you a band no I'm not
that cool
I'm a DJ why aren't you wearing a semi
helmet like all the other DJ's oh no I'm
not that kind of DJ I'm a real DJ I'm a
disc jockey hello like on the radio yeah
exactly I talk into a microphone I get
to interview interesting people don't
you think people should be able to see
you if people could see what you look
like you'd be a lot more famous poppy
yes what it's interesting and remarkable
idea you have you should take a lot more
selfies anyone have to work so hard
anymore where have you been last 23
years I have been doing it wrong the
entire time
are you doing great good of the guard
office do but it's right there now you
know what it's like to have a completely
neutral attitude and outlook on our
meaningless existence